now that's more what I'm talking about
it really is like the somehow the show
can hear what I'm talking about it is
just like okay okay we'll fix in the
next one and they usually do um just the
title alone when extremes meet I mean
how is that not a tempting title how can
you not be like oh what's that gonna be
that's a great time oh I got a stroke
that's a Simpsons reference to those who
really had strokes I apologize but okay
so this is how it feels like this is
getting good and this is getting you
know what's going oh that's going on
here
this is one that's much more set focused
on Tarlac and sort of his plan and
you're going much more into the issue
between the benders and the Equalists
and and just the people in between and
this gets into some very interesting
territory where once again sort of like
what they what they're doing with x-men
and a lot of these are shows us are talk
about prejudice and talk about well is
that you know that these stereotypes
come from somewhere but it's
nevertheless a stereotype but at the
same time that are people who use those
stereotypes to their advantage and they
use it as a weapon and they do use it to
abuse and so because of that people see
some people abusing power and they
associate it as all and that is an
extreme and extremes drive me insane
most of the time sometimes we need
extremes I mean there there's no doubt
about that but for the most part it is
just it's so one-sided and not open and
not compromising and so rarely does that
work like this joke and Avatar trying to
teach it you need that balance and here
we pretty much have tarrlok abusing his
power essentially he's going around
there's people going to as equal as
rally but they're not doing anything
they're just curious
they want to know what this is about and
he tries to have them all arrested he
tries to you know have them place under
control and Cora and her team come in
and say hey this is this isn't anything
you know that this is pretty much the
McCarthy trials you know are you part of
the Communist Party have you talked to
anyone the Communist Party it's playing
to that paranoia and they're using their
power and their fear to control and
korres say no this isn't cool i mean
yeah we obviously don't agree with what
they're talking about but they still
have a right to do this and she tries to
fight for them see this is this is good
stuff I mean this is interesting stuff
and then we see more and more just how
far gone tarrlok kind of is but you know
where he's coming from
- it's not entirely unrelatable oh god
and the scene where they have the final
conversation great location
thank you God just a different room and
it's a great looking Ruby's got this
waterfall behind them with these cool
designs and then I'm saying like oh I
hope they have a fight sequence but even
if they don't is a great-looking room
and boom they have a sequence in there
in it yes yes that's what I'm looking
for you know it doesn't have to be up
whatever 12 countries over five nations
over whatever it is I mean it's like
shut up air conditioning uh you just
need to have something look different
and they've been playing with the angles
but it's still the same room and here we
got a different romance a cool room it's
a cool location and then they bring the
fighting into whatever the the council
room where the meetings go on and stuff
like that and that was kind of neat and
they add another part of the story with
somehow our leg nose blood bending
without using the moon again that's
that's to do things that we have here
that are really kind of ripping you got
uh oh shut up
I'm sorry my air-conditioning wait to go
I have no idea why um but you got this
hell is I my air-conditioning may may
lose my train of thoughts
oh you're such a good thought - I don't
know if I can continue III thought these
V logs are going well and now it's just
like air conditioning no it just
destroyed the whole thing God maybe my
life isn't why maybe I should just like
end it right now I mean like just put
myself the edge of a bridge and sing a
song like Chabert I get the good Chabert
not throw so Cooper pick the way you
like really really end it all maybe just
God yes everything just been enough wait
no I remember okay so you got the two
there and they're fighting and so you're
wondering if a man can take away the
power the bending power and tarrlok can
blood Bend when it's not a full moon
somehow these two had to be interlinked
and somehow it's allowing them to do
stuff that nobody else can do but but
what's allowing that what this is entry
this is what lost was doing and they did
very well until they told you they
didn't have anything but the lead of was
great and avatar did have something I'm
sure this will have something because
avatar proved that they had something so
this is great and on top of that the
character stuff is very interesting and
leaves on a good cliffhanger for the
characters - you got a Korra being sent
away she's tied up in a van or something
and they're taking her somewhere we
don't know where and you have the rest
of the group they're in prison and
that's a good cliffhanger a lot of these
cliffhangers haven't even been grabbing
me that much I remember one of them was
like you know all those other benders
are really good we may not win the
competition tears here this is legit
stop going on uh so yeah I mean to me
this really felt like and I love that
scene where I love anything that shows
Korra as a hothead but sort of a
justified hothead like you get it and
when you see tar like a blue abusing his
power and then arresting the frenzy just
see you pick up those two rocks those
two Jai
boulders and you know she could just
crush him like the coyote and
nevertheless the friends are like no no
you should back down back down she puts
him down it's like I love moments like
that I just love it's like no no this
person could crush you but they didn't
they they have that ethical side um so I
like that is she was more interesting in
this and the our characters come more
interesting and yeah you got that scene
where what's-her-name the daughter looks
in the rearview and sees korimako like
we can teach everything she said mmm
like that it's just a girl but
nevertheless you still got this pretty
solid episode that's really diving more
into what the characters are capable of
where they draw the line how far they
should go and just the issues of of
prejudice and extremes and I don't know
it to me it seemed like a really good
episode saying hey we're gonna start
really sort of saying where the limits
are where they could be where they
shouldn't be and it does it very well um
and even that scene just out in just
outside way with the other people going
to the equalist rally whatever a great
lighting in that scene I mean oh oh you
have was the lighting from the cars and
a lot to their backlit or their or their
overexposed and it looked really good
and really stylized and the show we
stylize but is one a few times where you
sort of find a location where and they
can really have fun with the lighting on
that one
you know most of the lighting just stays
very dark night ish you know it's like
just sort of gray and orange and which
is cool for a bit and it's like oh this
is it okay but they play with the
lighting there and then again you have
that wonderful fight scene near the end
with that great waterfall and using the
water bending there and you see her
using the techniques that she used you
know with the spinny door thingies and
it's I don't know but to me it's like
yes here we go keep it going keep it
going
I can't see how you cannot keep it going
after having her tied up in the van of
being sent somewhere by the bad guys
it's like there's no way you cannot keep
that going so
now I'm excited again where the last
episode it's like oh come on it's just
just the endings you give a little bit
and that's it it's like here it's like
this whole episode was like whoa hey
okay this is interesting and I like it
when they're sort of going rogue - and
they sort of doing their own thing and
they were they're kind of like their own
little a-team going on so yeah that this
episode was great I I hope the rest are
like this I mean cuz Gaborik getting
pretty far now aren't we even like
almost close to the end let's keep them
going keep the momentum going guys so
guys who have made this show already but
I will still nonetheless blame if you
didn't listen to me
somehow by traveling in time so uh yeah
really liked this episode can't wait for
the next one